gaza se levantará de nuevo sin saber
cuándo puede estallar el próximo
bombardeo estas son imágenes de la
conferencia para la reconstrucción de la
ciudad celebrada en 2009 tras 22 días de
ataques israelís por tierra y aire
entonces distintos líderes mundiales
acordaron un fondo de cuatro mil 481
millones de dólares para reedificar el
territorio palestino en 2014 naciones
unidas- creó el mecanismo de
reconstrucción de gaza después de una
ofensiva de 50 días entre julio y agosto
de ese mismo año ahora la organización
pide que se respete el alto al fuego
para que vuelva a circular la ayuda
humanitaria y se reanude la
reconstrucción a la que se destinarán 18
6 millones de dólares
israel acostumbra a perder la guerra de
la opinión pública pero no pierde a su
mayor aliado eeuu no hay cambios en mi
compromiso con la seguridad de israel
punto no hay cambio pero les diré en lo
que si hay cambios continuamos
necesitando una solución que pase por la
vía de los dos estados es la única
respuesta
y es que tras 11 días cesaron las
hostilidades pero no se resolvieron más
de 70 años de conflicto realmente lo que
se necesita es que la comunidad
internacional obligue a ambas partes de
este conflicto tanto a la autoridad
palestina y representantes de hamás por
más que se niegue el estado de israel y
por supuesto al gobierno israelí a
sentarse a una mesa de negociación en el
medio corto plazo porque realmente se
necesita negociar fronteras para un
estado soberano palestino algo que
parece que yo vaivén quiere defender
pero no sabemos qué plan va a proponer a
ambas partes israel se retiró de gaza en
2005 sin embargo ejerce el control del
espacio aéreo de las aguas territoriales
y de la frontera terrestre de la franja
un bloqueo sin salida para dos millones
de personas